SAGE: OK.
Hi, I'm Sage.
I'm happy to introduce
Michael Witwer.
Michael's a professional actor,
a marketing professional,
and most importantly
to us today,
he wrote a book called
"Empire of Imagination"
that dives into the
history of Gary Gygax
and the games of
Dungeons and Dragons.
Bringing Michael here is
particularly exciting for me
because I'm a gamer
and a D&D fan.
And sharing an interest in D&D
is a surprisingly personal bond
to share with people,
gamers, all over the world.
So it's only fitting
that Michael's book
is a personal history
of Gary Gygax that
goes into family
stories, and anecdotes
and tells it from a
narrative point of view.
So please join me in
welcoming Michael Witwer.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL WITWER:
Thank you very much.
I'm thrilled to be here.
I mean, honest to goodness.
When Sage reached
out and told me
that Google wanted
me to do a talk,
I couldn't get my head
around, to be honest.
I'm like, are you sure they
shouldn't be talking to me?
How am I talking to Google?
That doesn't make any sense.
So I was really humbled and
I was thrilled about it.
And the more I thought
about it, it occurred to me,
you know, of course
it makes sense
of that the most relevant
technology company out there
would want to know
more about Gary Gygax.
And in fact, this group is
exactly the kind of group
that understand how
important this guy really
has been to pop culture.
Especially, kind of, now
more than ever, really.
As these concepts of
tabletop role-playing games
have kind of silently
and subversively
taken over our culture
to a certain extent.
Today, what I'd
like to do is talk
a little bit about how and
why I came to write the book.
And the reason I want to talk
about that actually is it
can't really be
separated from how
the book-- about why the
book, I guess, is important.
Or why Gary's story-- I
guess, more of the point--
is important today.
To everybody that's out there.
And I will tell you
right off the bat
that this is a book I
did not mean to write.
I did not set out
to write a book
about Gary Gygax or anybody
else for that matter.
This is something that
happened very organically.
And that was, kind of, one
of the interesting takeaways
for me is that, really,
it was Gary's importance
and Gary's contribution
that, kind of, made
it happen very organically.
It wasn't me pushing it along.
And I'll get into
that in a little bit.
And that's one reason I want
to share my story about it.
So a little bit about myself.
I've been playing role-playing
games, tabletop role-playing
games since I was
five years old.
My brother and my
dad and I all went
to a neighborhood
friend's house who
was selling all of his
late '70s AD&D books.
And I'll never forget it.
So we bought this two foot high
stack of AD&D books for $80
and we took them home.
And my brother was three
years older than myself
so he was really into it.
For me, I was just a little kid.
And so he devoured these books.
And he was so intrigued
by the concepts.
And he's always been
a very theatrical guy.
So I was one of his guinea pigs.
Me and my friend Nick,
we were his guinea pigs.
We made our fighters and
we would explore dungeons.
And we were just ruthless
because we were five years old.
So we would make fighters
and we would kill everyone
and anything that we could.
And sure enough, my
brother would always
get really frustrated
with us and he
would kill us in
some terrible way
because he's
frustrating with us.
So I've been playing
tabletop role-playing
since I was very little.
And we ended up transitioning
into Star Wars role-playing
game, the West End d6 version.
If anyone knows that.
And we play that
for years and years.
And we've played many, many
iterations of both Star Wars
and D&D at this point.
So I've got a pretty good--
and everything in-between.
I mean, the Amber
Diceless Roleplaying Games
you get really in the weeds on.
And all kinds of
different things.
So I love role-playing
games and that's always just
been a passion of mine.
And perhaps not incidentally,
I fell into theater
and performing arts.
It was something that I
was very interested in.
Something I did
through high school
and did it through college.
And I ended up
actually graduating
with a theater and music
degree at Northwestern.
And so that's what I
wanted to do for a living.
My ambition was to be a theater
performer, and so I came out
and I started doing that.
And I realized that, despite
what anyone might tell you,
theater is not very profitable.
And it's just not a
very good lifestyle.
It's a hard profession.
You do it for the
love of the game.
So I'm out there doing
that and I basically--
not to get to in
the weeds on it--
I fall into proposal writing.
I fall into product marketing.
It was a job that came
along, I needed money
and I happened to be a writer.
So I took it.
And probably better
lucky than good,
but I had a lot of
early success in it.
It went very well.
And, in fact, to
this day I continue
to lead a team of
proposal writers
for the company I
work at these days.
It's a health care company.
So I've been in proposal
writing, business writing,
grant writing for more than
10 years at this point.
So the writing I'm doing,
what most of us do, we grind.
Life is not done exactly
what we expect it to do.
I wasn't on Broadway, instead I
was writing business proposals
for a company.
And I entered a Master's program
at the University of Chicago
to, kind of,
broaden my horizons.
I was thinking at
this point, well, what
am I going to do with my life?
And I thought doing
a liberal arts
program might be a really
fun thing to, kind of, get
me diversified.
To see what I might
want to do next.
And I knew, at the
end of the program,
there was going to be a Master's
thesis that would be, kind of,
another stepping stone
for whatever I wanted
to do with my life at the end.
I would take all that
I've learned here,
and, kind of, summary it
in a big Master's thesis
and then I would go and
launch into something else.
This is going
somewhere, I promise.
So I'm in the program and
I'm, kind of-- and again,
this is a continuing program.
So I continue to write my
business proposals on the side
and I'm taking this
management program.
And as the thesis gets
closer and closer,
and as the program expiration
gets closer and closer,
I've got nothing
on the thesis side.
I think I'm going to
have this great clarity
and I've got no clarity.
And I'm down a rabbit
hole with the concept
I've been working on for
about a year and a half.
Which was about
Mayan urban planning.
OK.
Didn't think so.
There was nothing there.
I was down a rabbit hole.
And it was at this time that
I stumbled on an article
about Gary Gygax.
It was an article
written shortly
after he passed away in 2008.
And what struck me about
it was-- keeping in mind,
that I knew role-playing games.
To me, Gary Gygax was just the
name on the front of a book.
I had never thought a
lot about Gary Gygax.
If anything, he was
the shadowy character
that lived up the road in
Lake Geneva, Wisconsin.
I'm from Chicago.
And he had all these
shadows around him
because he was associated
with this game that
was all about Satan worship,
and psychological dangers,
and all this stuff.
So I never thought
about Gary Gygax.
But I read this article and I'm
just stunned at how interesting
and how full a life he had led.
And not just the things
that he had, kind of, done.
But it just seems that his story
was just a really interesting
rags-to-riches-to-rags
story by itself.
Independent of any of these
interesting company things that
had happens at TSR,
his company, or any
of these controversies that
existed around the game.
So I thought, wow, what
an interesting topic.
So I actually went to find
a biography about Gary Gygax
and I couldn't.
And I thought, whoa, this is--
this was a mind blower to me.
Now, can you give a raise of
hands how many people here
play tabletop role-playing
games or some derivative game?
Awesome.
OK, great.
I was hoping you'd say that
so I don't have to explain
what a role-playing game is.
Which is good.
So, to me, my mind was blown
because I thought to myself--
as someone who's been playing
role-playing games since I was
five years old, I'm
looking around today
and I'm seeing huge, major,
multimillion dollar pop culture
phenomenon that have a lot
of their roots in tabletop
role-playing games.
Concepts that used to be
unique to the tabletop
have started to show up.
Whether it be MMOs, such
as "World of Warcraft,"
or whether it be "Final Fantasy"
computer role-playing games.
I mean, the list goes
on and on and on.
I mean, even elements-- as
many people in this room
would attest to-- even
elements of social media--
the gamification,
character building aspects
of social media-- have some
of the roots, at least,
in tabletop role-playing.
So I thought, how can this
guy not have a biography?
He set into motion
something that
has hugely, far-reaching
consequences.
So that's what really got my
brain spinning on this issue.
And so that's when I actually
shifted my thesis project
to be a biographical
project about Gary Gygax.
I mentioned earlier that it
was a book I didn't mean write.
It still wasn't a
book, it was a project
that I was just very
passionate about.
So I dove into this thing.
And one thing that occurred to
me about the writing process
of it, which I thought
was really cool,
was that being from the
role-playing community,
I realized that, gosh, the hall
of famers of role-playing game
design are uniquely
accessible people.
It wasn't like I was trying to
write a biography about, say,
Bill Gates where I probably
wouldn't have access
to the people that I would
need to speak to really get
this great scoop.
This was a situation where I
can go to gaming conventions
and see the hall of famers,
kind of, around you.
And these were people that were
eager to share their story.
And in, kind of, be able to tell
you what their experiences were
with Gary.
And in most cases, they
were extremely generous
with their information.
They were dying to
tell their story,
their experiences with Gary
and their personal stories.
So that's what was really cool
was that, all of a sudden,
I actually had the
access to the people
I knew I could
really get the scoop.
So I dove into this process,
both feet first, really.
Or head first, whatever
the expression is.
And what I figured
out really quickly
was that-- so A, Gary's life was
hugely interesting by itself.
I mean, it was
rags-to-riches-to-rags.
His personal life, it
had highs and lows.
And it was really just
an interesting and very
dynamic story.
And when I paired that with what
I knew about TSR, when I began
to really realize about TSR.
Now TSR was the
company that Gary
founded to produce
Dungeons and Dragons.
Now this story,
in and of itself,
is every bit as interesting
as Apple or Facebook.
Or maybe Apple and
Facebook combined.
I mean, there was, basically,
all kinds of back biting.
There ended up being
a hostile takeover,
that's how Gary Gygax,
kind of, left the company.
So I thought there's, kind
of, a second point that
was really interesting, in terms
of what was there company wide.
And then there's was
this third element,
that's kind of
incomparable, which
is the controversy
around the game.
The thing that
actually both kept it,
kind of, in the shadows
for it's life but also
propelled it to front page news
and great success as it were.
So I found a story that was
really interesting one and one
that I really had to
tell at this point
So I went through
this process again.
As many interviews, as much
reading as I could possibly do.
And, fortunately, Gary
was a prolific writer
and left behind a huge record,
as did a lot of his associates,
so you could really get a
really good picture of what
was happening here.
So good news is I
finished the project,
that I got my Master's.
So there we have that.
That took, I don't know,
maybe 14, 15 months.
And at this point, it was
kind of mission accomplished.
I was like, OK, I did
what I set out to do.
I got to do all
these cool things.
And it occurred to
me-- I had, probably,
maybe 50,000 words
at that point--
and I thought, well, jeez.
This probably wouldn't take
that much more to be a book.
So that's when my wheels
really got spinning.
And this whole time, I continued
to work on the manuscript,
if you will.
I continued to do interviews,
I'm doing more research.
I'm digging more
into the material.
And, I figured,
let's check this out.
Let's see if there's
actually a book here.
So I started the
agency query process
and I go through
that whole thing.
And I was very fortunate that
we got picked up pretty quickly
on the agency side.
And we got the book sold
in a couple of short months
after that.
So that really speaks
to how much, at least,
some people understood how
important this Gary Gygax
guy really was.
So that was the
story of the book
and how it came about
very organically.
What I wanted to
tell-- what I wanted
to talk about a little bit today
was Gary himself, of course.
I'm sure you didn't come to
this to hear my story of how
I wrote the book.
But, in fact, who was
this guy, Gary Gygax?
What did he do and
why do we care?
For me, Gary's story is
hugely inspirational.
This is a guy that-- so
he was born in Chicago.
And I'm not going to bring
you through the whole history.
In fact, that's why we have the
book just so you could read it.
If it could be
told in 30 minutes,
there wouldn't be
much of a book.
So he's born in Chicago.
He's a Midwestern guy.
He moves to the small town
of Lake Geneva, Wisconsin.
And he lives a very, kind of,
normal, Midwestern lifestyle.
Midwestern mischief is what I
call it somewhere in the book.
I mean, he's out there,
he's doing pranks.
He's wandering around the
abandoned insane asylum
in town which, of course,
sparked, I'm sure,
a lot of interesting
imagination.
But it's a guy that
also had a lot of really
interesting challenges.
And this is some of
the stuff that really
got my attention about Gary.
A couple things I
wanted to point out,
you can call them items
of interest, if you will.
So Gary, as a kid, had two
paranormal experiences,
or what he thought to be
that were very formative to him.
Things he talked about
later in his life.
And again, you look at Gary
later on, you look at his work,
you think, wow.
Interesting. "Tomb
of Horrors" and a lot
of these modules, this
work that he had worked on.
You can see the
roots of this stuff
in some of these
experiences that he had.
And that was one reason why
it was really important for me
when I took on the work, that
the piece be comprehensive.
That we cover Gary from his days
as a young child all the way
through his death in 2008.
Because what really
occurred to me
was that Dungeons
and Dragons didn't
start in a single day in
1974 when Gary published
the first 1,000 copies.
It really started when he
played his first game of chess
at five years old.
Or when he used to roam the
abandoned insane asylum.
Or when he had these
paranormal experiences.
These are formative stuff,
they're the seeds of D&D,
if you will.
Another important
thing that I thought
was worth a mention at
least is that Gary never
had a driver's license.
Which is, to me,
kind of a big wow.
To think that a guy that
did so much with his life
couldn't drive a car-- or
didn't drive a car, to be exact.
There were some very interesting
circumstances around that
that we talk about in the book.
But pretty amazing
story in that respect.
This guy's a high
school dropout.
He dropped out his junior
year of high school
and never returned.
He did a short stint
in the military
and then went off to
work in insurance.
He was an insurance underwriter
for 10 years there after.
Got married young,
had five kids.
I mean, this guy had so
much going on with his life,
it's kind of
incredible that he was
able to build this
thing that he did.
And that's why the story
was so inspirational to me
is that here's a guy
that, if you could really
get into his head-- that's
something I really tried
hard to do with the book--
let's think about a guy that
is taking the train from
Lake Geneva to Chicago
where he works every day.
So an hour and a half there,
an hour and a half back.
He gets home, he sees his,
well, ever-growing family.
It was, one, then two, then
three, four, five kids.
And then he's spending
all-nighters writing games.
And, of course,
he was doing this
for years and years and
years before D&D ever
hit the shelves.
This is, kind of, an
amazing and inspiring story.
I mean, it was
all-nighters, all the time.
That was how much passion and
how much energy Gary Gygax
had for this whole thing.
Another item of
interest that I thought
I would point out that a
lot of you probably know
is Gary founded GenCon in 1968.
Now, of course, GenCon now
is one of the largest gaming
conventions in the country.
It's over 60,000 people.
It's a huge deal, it happens
in Indianapolis every year.
Well, this was
all the brainchild
of Gary Gygax, who founded
this thing in Lake Geneva.
It was called the Lake
Geneva Wargames Convention.
And it was one of the
first efforts of somebody
who really figured
out that there
was this disparate audience of
wargamers and miniature players
and diplomacy players
and that they all
needed to be brought together.
That wouldn't it be great if
we could get all these gamers
together, from all around
the country, to play games?
And that's what he did.
And this, of
course, was how Gary
was able to leverage these
communities into something
bigger with D&D later.
And this is all very
much part of his story.
But again, I think very
much worth a mention.
So, as the history
goes-- and I'll
get a little bit into
the history here just
to whirl in everybody--
so he founds
Gencon and he's
building this community
of wargamers and
miniature players
and these types of things.
And he meets a young
gentlemen named Dave Arneson
from the Twin Cities.
And Dave is very interested in a
lot of the same things Gary is.
He's working on a lot of
his own gaming variance,
he's working with miniatures,
he's working with wargames.
And Gary and Dave meet
at GenCon 2 in 1969.
And they start talking and
they're both interested,
of course, in a lot
of the same stuff.
And they start collaborating
on some games, some games that
actually have some of
the root concepts of D&D.
So this takes a few years.
Dave is, kind of, doing his
own thing in the Twin Cities
with his own gaming group.
Gary is doing his own stuff
in Lake Geneva with his gaming
group.
So the collaboration
goes back and forth.
And so by 1974, they've
put all the pieces together
of these formerly disparate
audiences-- so, you could say,
board gaming, miniatures
and diplomacy--
and they come out with this
one of a kind game, Dungeons
and Dragons.
Of course, a game that is unlike
anything else that's out there.
It has this character
assumption, first person
narrative, group
storytelling aspect to it.
But it also, of course,
has very real mechanics
in which you can play the game.
No one else is doing
this type of thing.
Well, I think, the
history, kind of,
is written on the
wall from there.
The game takes off.
It becomes a really
exciting thing
among the wargaming
community as well as
the miniatures community.
People don't know what
to do with this thing
but they love it.
And they can't get enough of it.
So the company begins
to grow very quickly,
and like so many companies
that are started with passion,
people that are doing for
the love the game, here's
a situation where
this company, TSR,
that they form to
make the game--
and this is not Dave Arneson
but Gary and a couple
of his partners-- neither one
of them is a good businessman.
They're all bad
businessmen and they're not
good at what they do.
So as a result, they're
designing great games,
but they don't know
how to take of money
as it starts rolling in.
And they don't know
how to structure
fair royalty agreements,
a lot of other things.
So the company has
a lot of problems.
And as I mentioned, it's every
bit as interesting as Apple,
Facebook, you name it.
By 1976, Arneson is brought
into the company to work,
and 10 months later, is
either fired or leaves.
That is still open to a little
bit of debate and mystery.
And I get into that a little
bit in the book as well.
That's important because, a
couple years later, Arneson
ends up filing a lawsuit against
TSR for copyright infringement
for some things that
happened between them.
So really, all of this
success starts to unravel,
starting around 1979.
Where things at TSR are going
great, then all of a sudden,
they've got a lawsuit on their
hands with the co-creator.
And that, kind of, equals
bad press and a lot
of stress for Gary personally.
The thing that really
propels TSR though,
from the hobby channelist to,
really, the mainstream front
pages is an incident
that happens
in Michigan State University
in Lansing, in East Lansing,
in 1979.
A young Michigan State student
named James Dallas Egbert
III disappears mysteriously.
James Dallas Egbert
III was two years
younger than his
fellow classmates.
He had a lot of problems.
He was, kind of, a geek
in the classical sense.
He was two years younger.
He was very interested
in technology.
He was a little
guy, he was 5' 3".
He had a lot of issues,
like anybody has,
and he disappears mysteriously.
And people are trying to figure
out what happened to him.
Well, James Dallas Egbert
III happens to play D&D.
So his parents send in
a private detective,
a guy named William
Dear, to investigate
what happened to their son.
And Dear finds these D&D books
in James Dallas Egbert's room
and comes up with
a theory that he
has disappeared
because the game has
blurred the lines between
fantasy and reality.
That the human mind simply
cannot deal with the fact that
you can assume a character at
a tabletop but you can also be
in this world as we know it.
So, yeah-- no, it's-- right.
I mean, this is
what he suggests.
So this is an idea that
he leaks to the media.
Well, so this becomes
a media circus.
It becomes a feeding
frenzy for media attention.
A couple weeks later,
this particular theory
makes the front page--
not the front page
but it makes "The
New York Times."
It becomes a national story.
So all of the sudden,
TSR is scrambling
because they're being accused
of being psychologically
dangerous to people,
teenagers specifically,
because their game blurs
this tenuous balance of fact
and fiction.
The irony of the whole thing
is that a couple weeks later,
James Dallas Egbert III is
discovered in Louisiana.
Dear finds him.
He's safe and sound and it has
nothing to do with the game.
He just ran away because
he has lots of problems.
And yet, this theory that had
become pervasive in the media
was never expressly retracted.
So this theory about
the game, kind of,
grows unfettered in media minds.
So much so that the
following year, a big novel
is released by Rona Jaffe
called "Mazes and Monsters"
which becomes a 1982 TV
film, starring Tom Hanks.
A great film, by the way,
if you haven't seen it.
It's a must.
So here, this game,
this theory continues
to grow even though this case
has been resolved years ago
and was all based on
complete speculation.
No fact in it.
And it was this
level of scrutiny
around the game,
this is bizarre,
intellectual game
some people called it,
that led to some of these
further accusation of the game
associated with Satan worship
and all of these crazy things
that had nothing to
do with the game.
Now, of course, religious
fundamentalists and censors,
kind of, teamed up to really
throw this game into the fire,
as it were.
So it became a really
interesting thing.
But here's the big takeaway
of this whole thing.
All press is good press, right?
So once the story broke
and became national news,
TSR's revenue quadrupled
in the year that followed.
And it had been doing
well before that,
but it quadrupled because, of
course, the same game that you
were reading about in the
tabloids, of course, now
you could find on the shelves
of your local bookstore.
It was a pretty amazing thing.
And so the very same thing that
still hangs over this game--
this weird black
cloud, if you will,
that hangs over this
game, to this day,
in some circles-- is the
same thing that actually
propel its success
and made it, really,
a fairly mainstream thing.
So I thought that was, kind of,
worth going over a little bit.
I also wanted to
talk about the fact
that for Gary, business
as much as it was great
that for him that business was
good, this was very hard on him
personally.
Because my book focuses
very much on the man,
I really wanted to
get into the head of,
kind of, what he's going through
as these accusations come up
because that was
very hard on him.
A lot of really rough things
happened between 1979 and 1985,
and all of this
culminates with him being
ousted from his own company.
I mentioned that Gary
had to do a lot of things
to get this company
off the ground.
One which is he had
taken on a lot partners
and he made a lot of
royalty agreements
that we're not very
favorable for the company.
For the company or for Gary.
So by 1985, he briefly
regains control of his company
but, basically, his former
partners sell their interest
to somebody who
had been brought in
to help stabilize the company.
And they kick Gary out.
So Gary's ousted from his
own company about 10 years.
And I thought that was so
interesting because, again, it
really mirrors so
many things that you
see in these companies that
are founded with passion.
Whether it be Steve Jobs
stories or Jerry Yang.
I think it's really interesting
that these guys that
start-- these
people, I should say,
that start these companies with
a certain amount of passion
can end up with very
little to show for it.
I think that's the
case with Gary.
He led a very dynamic
life but he, kind of,
come out with very
little to show for,
at least financially, after
TSR and Dungeons and Dragons
came and went.
And he spent the
rest of his career,
kind of, trying to recreate
what was Dungeons and Dragons.
You know, lightning never really
struck twice for Gary again.
But I think what
became really cool,
is that late in the
'90s and the 2000s,
Gary started to get some
interesting attention
from those who had played his
game and grew up playing it.
And I think this
is really where--
this is a very important
part of my book--
is that Gary has this
really interesting reversal.
That he starts to
be acknowledged
for these great
things he had done.
And he had never really
thought of it that way.
It just kind of happened.
And, at the end of the day,
I think the big takeaway--
for me, anyway--
was that Gary had
created this empire
of imagination
because the early people that he
had played in his game happened
to be the same people that we're
working on early computers.
And they were early performing
artists and directors
and they were into all
these interesting things.
And in aggregate,
what ends up happening
is that people that he built
this empire of imagination
because he's fostering these
people's imagination, and all
of a sudden, these
people become the masters
of the information age.
And they're starting to
give Gary Gygex credit.
So that was, kind
of, the big a-ha
for me was that this guy, almost
by the transitive property,
based on how big a lot of
these concepts have become,
is a very, very important guy.
Thank you.
Thank you back there.
I did want to go to
jump into some questions
because I know there's
going to be a lot.
At least, I hope there are.
So, why don't we open the
floor for questions, please.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Were you able
to talk with Arneson?
MICHAEL WITWER: Was I
able to talk with Arneson?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHAEL WITWER: Arneson
passed away in 2009.
I didn't start the
project until 2012.
So no, I wasn't able
to speak with Arneson.
Naturally, I read
a lot of his work,
and saw a lot of
interviews and whatnot.
But no, I wasn't able to
speak with Arneson directly.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Who created Chainmail?
MICHAEL WITWER: Good question.
So the easy answer is Gary
Gygax created Chainmail.
Chainmail was a
miniatures game that
was published about four years
before Dungeons and Dragons.
As I mentioned,
before D&D came out,
there was a lot of
different types of gaming.
And they were all disparate
factions of gaming.
You had miniatures over here,
you had wargaming over here.
Wargaming was, basically, think
of hex max maps and cardboard
contras or pogs.
And then you've got diplomacy
in the middle, which
is kind of this game
where you could play it
a few different ways--
you can play it by mail--
but it's a game where there's
a certain amount of character
assumption.
And you play the game
through negotiation and guile
and other means.
So it's a very
different type of game.
And you could argue,
again, that these three
disparate components
make up the elements that
become a role-playing game.
So Gary Gygax had founded
this local gaming group
in Lake Geneva and they
used to play miniatures
on his sand table that he
had built in his basement.
And they came up
with these, kind of,
homebrew rules about, basically,
the mechanics of how one
would play minutures wargames.
There's a lot of ways to do it.
Some people use rulers
and measurements,
there's just a lot of ways.
And Gary had teamed up with a
fellow named Jeff Perren, who
was a member of his
local gaming group,
and had started to
refine miniatures rules
for their homebrew game.
And that became a rule
set known as Chainmail,
published by Guidon Games.
Chainmail had a
lot of the classes,
and a lot of even
the combat mechanics
that one would recognize
in Dungeons and Dragons.
And so you could say Chainmail
was an important predecessor
piece.
And, in fact, it was
this game, Chainmail,
that became a major
inspiration to Dave Arneson
when he was rolling out a
game he called Blackmoor.
Dave Arneson was
playing what most of us
would recognize as the
first role-playing game
or something that at least
resembles a role-playing game,
with his Minneapolis
gaming group.
He called it Blackmoor.
He would use the Chainmail
rules for his combat.
And he would use some
of these other concepts
he had gotten through
diplomacy, and
through some other concepts,
that he had come up
in the Minneapolis gaming group
for this kind of role-playing
game called Blackmoor.
This is a game he showed to
Gary in 1972-- demonstrated,
I should say, for Gary in 1972.
That's when those two really
got together and start
working on what has become
Dungeons and Dragons.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Did you ever chance
to speak with his first wife?
MICHAEL WITWER: I spoke
quite a lot with Mary.
Mary Jo.
AUDIENCE: So what
was her thinking
of having a husband who spends
his nights doing this stuff
with five kids and all that?
MICHAEL WITWER:
It didn't go well.
[LAUGHTER]
You had mentioned,
it's his first wife.
There's a reason why
it was his first wife.
So one really
important thing to me.
I had mentioned that is was
really important that this book
be comprehensive.
I don't mean it covers every
fact and detail of Gary life.
Rather that I cover
every area of his life.
And one really
important part to that
was can I find somebody
that's was there
at every part of his life.
That was really
important because I
write the book in a
narrative, nonfiction style,
there is an oral history
element about the whole thing.
I wanted to get
into Gary's head.
And I wanted to be beyond
facts and figures, per se.
And so the question
is, could I get
to people that knew Gary
at every different part
of his life?
And the good news was not
only was Mary accessible--
and I spent a lot
of time with her--
but she knew Gary since
he was five years old.
They met in Lake Geneva when
they were five years old.
And so, all of a
sudden, I actually
had somebody that
knew Gary through all
these critical parts
of his early life,
that frankly, there's nobody
else there to talk about them.
Everyone else's is
either deceased--
And, of course, Gary writes a
lot about these things as well.
So you can, kind of, fill
in a lot of the gaps.
But I worked quite
a lot with Mary Jo.
And to answer your question.
So they had a very tumultuous
relationship, extremely.
And there's a lot
of reasons for that.
I mean, for one thing, Gary
was obsessed with hobbies.
Namely gaming but
a lot of things.
Gary was just that type.
He was your classic, kind
of, eccentric genius.
He just was.
He could not turn the spout off
of ideas that were rolling out
of him all the time.
And that was very hard
on their marriage.
This is a guy that would
come home many days.
after an hour and a
half on the train,
working as an
insurance underwriter.
He would sit down, he
might read his mail.
He might see whatever
diplomacy play-by-mail game
he was playing at the time.
See his kids briefly.
And he would retire
to his den where
he'd be writing on his next
game or his next gaming variant.
And the thing that was
striking about Gary,
when you looked at his
early life especially,
is the amount of production this
guy was able to keep up with.
Knowing that he had a
family and a full time job.
When you see how
much writing he's
doing in these various fanzines.
Fanzines are basically
early gaming newsletters,
for lack of a better term,
that these gaming groups would,
kind of, coordinate through.
And Gary's contributing to
these things on a monthly basis.
New gaming variants, new
letters, you name it.
He's constantly cranking out
material, he can't turn it off.
And, of course, that's
very hard on a marriage,
especially one that has
so many responsibilities.
And of course, meanwhile, they
don't have a lot of money.
They're struggling and when
Gary loses his job in 1970, when
Mary Jo is eight and
a half months pregnant
with her fifth child.
One can imagine this was quite
a strain on the relationship
also.
So, again, that's
something that I
think is very worth
reading in the book
just because it's such a
tumultuous relationship.
And a wonderful relationship.
It bore some really
wonderful things.
But by 1983, they were
ships passing in the night
and the love, kind
of, started to fade.
Yes.
SAGE: So there's been a number
of great books on the history
of Dungeons and Dragons
and role-playing games
the last few years.
Why do you think that now all
of these books are happening?
MICHAEL WITWER: Hmm.
That's a great question.
I mean, I think it comes
back, to a certain extent,
that the people who grew
up playing these games
are the ones that are the
most relevant in our society.
Oh, I shouldn't say
the most relevant.
That's an unfair thing to say.
Just that a lot of these
people have really become
the masters of the generation.
I mean, take John Favreau.
As a director, he
talks about D&D
taught him to be a storyteller.
Junot Diaz, the Pulitzer
Prize-winning author
of "The Brief Wondrous
Life of Oscar Wao,"
says that D&D was my
apprenticeship in storytelling.
Sam Lipsyte says that I
became a writer because I
couldn't be a Dungeon Master.
I wanted to be a Dungeon Master,
I wanted to control the story.
And the list goes
on and on and on.
Whether it be Steve
Colbert or Anderson Cooper.
A lot of these people that are
out there doing amazing things
found a lot of their
roots, and a lot
of their early creativity,
in Dungeons and Dragons.
So, I think, now
is the time where
there's a confluence
of all those things.
And I think people that were
early computer programmers
are starting to realize, wow,
I got a lot of these concepts
from the tabletop.
And, of course, they're showing
up on people's browsers.
And people that didn't grow up
playing Dungeons and Dragons,
or another role-playing
game, wouldn't necessarily
recognize that
these are concepts
that used to be unique
to a role-playing game.
So I think, to a
certain extent, I
guess the easy answer is
that we live in a time
when it is geek to be chic.
Or, it is chic to be
geek, to be exact.
Not geek to be chic.
I don't know what the means.
It's chic to be geek.
And so, who is more
relevant than the guy who
created the geekiest game of
all time, Dungeons and Dragons.
And honestly, I've been
thinking a lot about this.
Why is it cool to be geeky now?
What does that even mean?
And for me, geekiness,
all it means,
is it's unadulterated,
unencumbered enthusiasm
for something.
And it's funny because
when I grew up,
it wasn't cool to be a geek.
I mean, I guess that
goes without saying.
But it wasn't cool to be
really into something, right.
It was cool to pretend like
you didn't care and to not try.
That was the cool thing to do
in the '80s and '90s, right.
But so why is it
chic to be geek now?
To, really kind of,
really focus on something.
People can be geeky
about anything today,
whether it's gardening
or pottery or whatever.
And so, again, I
think the answer
is that it's cool to be
into things these days.
I think that's, kind of,
what our society demands, is
that we really focus and that we
apply ourselves to do something
greater than ourselves.
But then, I guess, the
big question for me
is, well, then why D&D players?
How are these people some
of the original geeks?
What was it about this
game that made it, kind of,
this fountain of creativity
in all these things?
And I think the answer
is that the game doesn't
work without a lot of
engagement and commitment.
So the people that were
playing this game in the '70s,
you couldn't play D&D--
And, in fact, the game
sucks if there's something
at the table that is not
committed, that is not engage.
It requires that everybody
really commit to this group
storytelling thing.
So, I guess, what
I'm trying to say
is that the game lends itself
to a culture of geekdom,
to a culture of unadulterated
enthusiasm for something.
You have to be enthusiastic
to play the game.
So, again, I wear it
as a big badge of honor
that we were some of
the original geeks
and this has become a
cool thing now, I guess.
An important thing.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So, on the
cover of your book,
you have, sort of, a
homage to Unearthed Arcana.
I was wondering,
why does that seem
like one of the more
iconic books for what
seems like a relatively
obscure rule supplement?
MICHAEL WITWER: That's
a great question.
I actually-- I talk about
it a little bit in the book.
Unearthed Arcana, first of all,
the cover art is spectacular.
I think we can agree that--
yeah, the original Jeff Easley
cover art.
So you'll notice that the
cover of my book, of course,
is a referential piece
if you know that piece.
It's originally a wizard
with a big tome in his castle
and whatnot.
And I got the same
artist, Jeff Easley,
to do my cover, which is Gary,
of course, at his typewriter.
Instead of the
wizard, it's Gary.
It's a typewriter
instead of the book.
It's in his little den and
his various effects around.
And the reason that
we did that was A,
it was a cool thing to do.
I guess I thought
it was a neat thing
to do once I got to
know Jeff Easley.
But Unearthed Arcana was a
particularly important book,
not because it was a great
supplement, as you suggested.
It's kind of an
esoteric rule supplement
and it's really,
kind of, aggregated
pieces from the last few
years of Dragon Magazine,
as some of you probably know.
And they, kind of,
put them together.
It was, kind of,
hastily put together.
And one reason it was
is because the company
was strapped at the time.
When that book came
out, Gary had recently
just taking control,
retaken control, of TSR.
He had kicked out
his former partners
and the company was
in financial shambles.
It was bleeding money.
They had taken on
way too many staff,
they had really overgrown.
And so, that company--
that book, I should say,
was an important part in getting
that company back on track.
When they released
that book, I think
it sold 80,000 copies
in its first month.
It was a huge success
and it was actually
one of the first steps to
really getting the company back
to financial solvency.
So really, the story behind
the story in that case,
was particularly relevant.
And knowing Gary's contribution
to that book and his driving
behind that book, it
actually became, kind of,
symbolic for the book itself.
This struggle that
Gary's going through.
Other questions?
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Why is Gary Gygax
famous and Dave Arneson isn't?
MICHAEL WITWER: That's
a good question.
And that's-- well, they're
all good questions--
and you know what?
It's a very fair question
because Dave Arneson probably
should be as famous
as Gary Gygax.
Dave Arneson, absolutely.
Oh, thank you.
Yes.
The question was why is Gary
Gygax famous and Dave Arneson
not?
And it's a great question
because Dave Arneson
is the co-creator of
Dungeons and Dragons.
I would say there's probably
some pretty good reasons
for it, whether
they're fair or not.
Again, on record, Dave Arneson
is the co-creator of the game.
Dave Arneson is the first guy
that, probably, put together
some these disparate
pieces in something
that someone would recognize
as a role-playing game.
But he did it at the table
in a very improvised way.
So wasn't, per se, written down
in a very clean sort of way.
That's really happened when him
and Gary Gygax got together.
What is notable is that
Dungeons and Dragons
was Gary Gygax's piece.
He's the one that
physically wrote it.
physically produced it.
And, as a matter of
fact, it was his company
that he founded, TSR,
that produced it.
And it was done at
great personal expense.
He had basically
taken on two partners.
Don Kaye, his
longtime best friend,
who had to take out a loan
on a life insurance policy
to be able to fund
his part of the game.
Gary had no money.
His own mother wouldn't
loan him money for the game.
And he took on a third partner,
a guy named Brian Bloom.
Bloom and his family
ended up being
some of the really the big--
let me put it this way.
The Bloom brothers were a
very important part of TSR
because they provided
a lot of the funding.
These were the partners that
he ended up ousting in 1984.
So things didn't go very
well with the Blooms
in the long run.
But they were very important
to getting the company
off the ground.
So the answer, I think,
to the question really
is that D&D was a
Gary-driven product.
And I mean that as a product
because it became a product
and he was the one that
owned it, in a essence.
Arneson got a royalty on.
But once Gary's company
really went up and running.
And then once he did Advanced
Dungeons and Dragons,
which of course, is a
major revision to Dungeons
and Dragons.
That was a Gary Gygax product.
And that became, of course,
a big point of contention.
That was the reason behind the
lawsuit, as a matter of fact.
So I think the main reason
is that Gary, kind of, owned
the IP.
He owned the company and he was
the driving force behind it.
Once Arneson had
given those pieces,
he was, kind of, out of it.
And kind of faded into the
shadows, doing other projects,
important projects.
But I think that's
the easy answer.
Is that Gary was the front,
the face of TSR, if you will.
How are we doing
on the time, Sage?
SAGE: We're about out of time.
MICHAEL WITWER:
Wow, time flies when
you're having fun talking D&D.
SAGE: Yeah, we should leave
time for signing books.
So, um--
MICHAEL WITWER: Oh.
Thank you.
SAGE: If you could give a
round of applause for Michael.
And he'll be here to sign books.
[APPLAUSE]